from spring to autumn frank Schumacher
brings both locals and tourists across
the Elbe near on a Borg on a motor 'less
boat the rope ferry is driven solely by
the river's current it said that a ferry
went back and forth across the river as
early as the 15th century nithyananda
way of the few times i've been on the
ferry here in on a book for 23 years
counting my training it's 25 years it's
been a fantastic time a quarter of a
century it's wonderful driving to work
in the mornings enjoying the scenery and
seeing the animals I recommend it to
every visitor to him benny threatened
animal and plant species find a
protected habitat in the meadows along
the Elbe
there are very few bridges here that
protects the natural surroundings from
too much motorized traffic for
kilometers fairies are the only way to
cross the river the meadows near our nuh
Borg are part of the middle elba
biosphere reserve pheww so many people
visit the town of honor book and enjoy
the lovely view of the Elbe it's very
good but the best view is 25 meters
above the river valley that's where on a
Borg Park is and the best panoramic view
and that's where we're going now in the
Middle Ages there was a fortified
bastion on the hill because the Elbe
often served as a border between east
and west remains of the medieval walls
still stand in Arabic park Frank
Schumacher's first recommendation the
people of our de Burgh enjoy strolling
in the shade of the age old trees
the park here they don't make em any you
said this park reminds me of my youth
the peacefulness all I uh I've known my
wife from school I wanted but it was
here on the hill where we used to meet
to enjoy the quiet and cuddle a little
one but maybe you can also visit the
park and cuddle a bit yourself awake ma
& glam finish moving from the terrace a
bit higher up there's a panoramic view
of the middle elba which stretches over
400 kilometers to just outside Hamburg
Arn aboard lies on the West Bank its
houses were built in seventeen
seventy-six after a fire swept through
the town the statues on the market
square commemorate our new borges
venerable shipping and fishing
traditions Frank's second recommendation
is st. George's Church which dates from
the 12th century
when the archer chair in on a Borg is
the oldest in the off mark region you
should take a visit here bazoo
inside the field stone walls in the
simple interior of the Romanesque Church
there's a surprise of a rock altar it
was brought here from a chapel in
Quentin book
the lutheran church is open to everyone
from april to october Frank Schumacher's
third tip is his favorite restaurant in
the Golden arranca hotels
fish are the highlight at the golden
anchor
yeah I'm Kayla within the basement
there's a huge aquarium without seeing
tolls and it holds about 10,000 liters
of water and it's meant to represent a
cross-section of the Alba you can eat
fish here to you come on over ethin but
not the ones in the aquarium they're
just for show Frank Schumacher only has
time for a cup of coffee today then he
has to get back to his fairy after all
no one wanting to get from one bank of
the Elbe to the other in our new Borg
should have to wait
you